welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and i don't know if it's just me but
does anyone else think the stand
is randall lagging a bit after episode
three
i think by far this was my least
favorite of those released
and i found the time jumps to be a bit
all over the place
if you're confused by exactly what's
going on then don't worry
as we're going to be breaking it all
down and discussing the main book
differences
obviously full spoilers ahead from here
on out
though i will keep some of the bigger
elements of the book a secret to not
spoil some certain surprises
now if you enjoyed the video please
smash the thumbs up button
make sure you subscribe for breakdowns
of the series every week
without the way happy new year i'm your
host paul
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
episode 3 sort of fills in the
backstories of some of the side
characters that we've been introduced to
and primarily we focus on nadine and
nick now you may remember that
last week we caught nadine being drawn
towards a planchette
and in this episode we see the device
ties all the way back to her childhood
similar to the source material nadine
was an orphan
but rather than living with her aunt and
uncle like in the book
we see her starting off in a home
through the planchette randolph flag is
able to contact her
and he clearly has had eyes on her from
a young age
the villain carves into the floor nadine
will be my queen
we are in the house of the dead nadine
which which yeah you know what mate
you can have her now even as an adult
nadine is still a virgin
and this is because throughout her life
flag has contacted her and told her to
save herself for him
though many men have shot their shot
some dark forces always swept
in and scared them off but like i said
again yeah you can have a
now in the present we catch you waking
up in a bed and to everyone's surprise
amber hood hasn't pooped in here so i'll
stop i'm sorry
elsewhere larry and stu are doing their
rounds which is when a yellow sports car
arrives with a man from las vegas in it
if you've been paying close attention to
the series so far then you'll have
noticed the signs that have been placed
throughout flag's dreamscape
and larry himself was also tempted with
one that looked very similar to the car
key
though initially seems like this man has
escaped it's revealed that flag let him
go in order to send a message
now the source material goes into a lot
about why flag crucifies
those that he sees as defying his
commands and i actually felt like this
subplot was one of the better parts of
the episode
it let us know exactly what kind of
person he is without showing us
and makes vegas ever more intriguing
even though we know it might be some
weeks before we make it to the location
through nadine we see her first meeting
with larry in which
joe attacked him joe is sort of a feral
child in many ways that's seen a lot of
messed up stuff
and thus he has a murderous side to him
that makes him lash out
whenever he feels threatened he's
definitely the dark horse of the series
and what's worse is that nadine has an
influence over him
which obviously hints at what's in store
due to her connection with flag
through the flashbacks we also get
confirmation that rita
did indeed end her own life now in our
last breakdown i said that because they
didn't show her body
i thought they might be differing from
the source material in the book larry
wakes up to find her corpse and it's one
of the most shocking scenes in the work
but here they skipped over it so i did
hold out hope
however we do know that she is indeed
dead and who knows we might learn more
about larry waking up as we go down the
line
anyway nadine has been put in charge of
the school which is an
extremely dangerous position due to how
she can corrupt the minds of the
youngsters there
she also comes face to face with harold
who seems to spook joe slightly
and we discover that flag wants nadine
to recruit him at the end of the entry
when she's talking with larry we can
also see the signs left behind by harold
and as we know from last time he
followed these across the country
now we jump to franny getting an
ultrasound on her baby
and confirm that stew isn't the father
though this was never the case in the
book
after the first episode due to her not
telling her father she was pregnant
i did assume that things had changed and
they'd made stew the dad
but they stayed in line with the
original work in the end now what is
different though is that stew
doesn't stay with them after the first
encounter and it's clear early on that
harold views him as a threat
originally he joined the pair by hinting
towards harold that he didn't want to
ruin the pair's relationship
and that he wouldn't be making a move
this was of course a lie
but the changing of this allows for him
to meet glenn played by
none other than greg kinnear now what i
love about harold is that he pretty much
berates stew and clearly views him as
someone that will swoop fran off her
feet
rather than being a legitimate enemy
stew could have killed them at any point
had he wanted to
but harold still says that he could be
secretly jeffrey dahmer
when we know that he's more in line with
him than mr redman is
stew to me has always been the way that
harold wishes that he'd come across
but no matter how many tom cruise mirror
points he tries
he'll never quite fool fran stu is
pretty much the knight in shining armor
that comes in to rescue her
and it's gonna be interesting to see if
they meet up on the road again
or at their destination an interesting
question that fran asks is whether her
child could also have immunity
but before we get any answers the
crucified man is brought in
and things sort of segue into nick's
backstory
the death meat was assaulted in a bar at
shoyo and because of the attack he lost
sight in one of his eyes
in the original work his story very much
chronicled how captain trips ravaged the
town
but here it's cut down to just a
hospital visit now he also dreams of
flag who very much fills in his
backstory
using the metaphor of being dealt a bad
hand whilst showing cards to the
character
flag wants nick to become his right hand
man and as we know from last time
this job actually felt polloid i think
flag wants to attempt those that have
had a tough time with a better life
but nick declines it and thus this shows
abigail that he's worthy of being her
voice
nick is just a genuinely nice guy and is
even merciful to the guy that made him
lose his eye
which is symbolic in many ways flag very
much goes after people who have an eye
for an eye mentality
but the fact that nick literally loses
one and still comforts the person that
assaulted him
shows his strength of character now he
meets an autistic man named tom
who was sent from abigail and this is
mirrored in the meeting of stu and glenn
they're very much kindred spirits and
he's far more welcoming to stew than
harold was
hinting at the division that could be at
the camp before they even get there
now we learned that dogs horses and
guinea pigs are also killed by trips as
well
the latter is suggested by stew and as
we know from the first episode
they were kept in the medical center
where he was observed
through glenn's paintings he and stew
discover that they've both been having
dreams about abigail
after he uncovers franz one it's taken
as an omen
and they then head out together you also
see nick gains a voice from abigail
and though he was offered one by flag he
did turn it down
this gives us the idea that he's a good
judge of character and because of this
we know that abigail must be one too now
tom is actually a really kind-hearted
guy
and though he's not good with social
cues he definitely doesn't mean to do
anyone any harm in the source material
his father ran away when he was younger
and his mother raised him on her own
unfortunately
she also died of captain trips in the
work they flesh out their journey to
abigail's a lot more
and i can imagine that this will pop up
down the line because nick can't talk he
sort of has to pantomime things to tom
in order to communicate
and i hope they capture their friendship
in the series as it's one of the more
lighthearted moments of it
other than all the death and destruction
they see of course now cut to larry
singing baby can you dig your man at the
baseball stadium
and i kinda was hoping that we'd see the
yankee yanker from last time
but unfortunately he's not there not all
heroes wear capes
now this is a flashback on the road and
it's probably the moment that stuck out
to me
as being a bit disjointed this episode
yeah it jumps
back and forward through time quite a
lot and it just gets very muddled by the
end of it
with this being the prime example now
though i have my criticisms here
the composition of this moment is really
good as we see
larry reaching out to joe through music
and encouraging him to play
he's on one side whilst nadine is on the
other i think this hints to the audience
that going forward
these will pretty much be the two sides
that joe can choose from
in the present the committee gather to
discuss democracy
who should lead the group and whether
they should tell the settlers about flag
this discussion is interrupted by
abigail who talks to the man
and he reveals he brought a message to
her from flag
it's creepy as hell and hints towards
what's going on in vegas
during one of the flashbacks we actually
catch the carpet from the shining
which of course is another one of king's
works we also learned that flag has been
enslaving people
and in many ways loydin and dean are
slaves
though they are accepting of it during
the reveal
the man is possessed by flag in order to
deliver a message to abigail
and he tells her that he has blood in
his fists and that she should pray god
takes her before she hears his boots
he ends by saying i'm going to blow your
house down and this is a call back to
not only jack and the shining
but of course the big bad wolf we close
out the entry with nadine contacting
flag once more
and discover that she is indeed spying
on the camp for him
because of abigail flag can't enter it
and he's been using her as his eyes
even though she hates it in boulder flag
tells her that he wants the witch to be
killed
along with the other five puppets there
nadine twirls the stone that we saw her
with last week
and clearly she was longing for flag
when touching this
flag also used one to free lloyd and the
118 has
is obviously around for a special reason
now as we know
harold is unstable and already
contemplating murdering stu and fran
thus flag has singled him out and wants
nadine to be the one to push him into
doing this
this will allow her to remain in the
camp under the radar whilst harold takes
the fall
harold's mate already made nadine seem
like one of the most beautiful women on
earth
i think that this was put in place to
hint to him that
harold should basically worship her as
we know he has an unhealthy relationship
with women
and will go above and beyond to be with
one so i think this is a smart move by
flag
the episode ends with harold and his
mate chucking the crucified man's body
into a ditch
and he hauntingly says it'll be the
first of many
anyway that wraps up the episode and
don't forget that on the 30th of january
we're giving away three copies of the
hobbit
and lord of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
last week
which kind of goes over the ins and outs
of nadine's backstory
as well as what we could expect with joe
if not then
you know what as much as i don't like
you right now i hope you have a happy
new year and wish you all the best for
2021
you take care of yourself peace